Simplify n squared r
to the fifth n to
the negative seventh.
Express your answer in
exponential form
with positive exponents.
Let me just rewrite what
they have up there.
So we have n squared
r to the fifth n to
the negative seventh.
So the easiest way to simplify
this, I would say kind of just
while we were multiplying them,
group the common bases.
So we have two exponent
expressions with n as a base.
We have n squared and we have
n to the negative seventh.
So let me just rearrange this
multiplication right here.
I can rewrite this as n squared
n to the negative
seven and then we have
our r to the fifth.
And what's this going
to be equal to?
Well we have n squared times
n to the negative seven.
We can add those
two exponents.
So this right here would
simplify to n
to the 2 minus 7.
2 minus 7 is negative 5.
N to the negative 5,
r to the fifth.
Now we've simplified this
about as much as we can.
But, we're not done yet.
Because they said express your
answer in exponential form
with positive exponents.
This is a negative
exponent here.
This is not acceptable,
at least based on what
they asked us to do.
So we know that n to the
negative fifth is the same
thing as 1 over n
to the fifth.
So we can just rewrite
it the that way.
So this is the same thing
as 1 over n to the fifth
times r to the fifth.
Or we could say this is equal
to r to the fifth
over n to the fifth.
And this is about as simple
as you can you can get.
If you wanted to do other things
here you could say that
this is equal to r over
n to the fifth.
Since both of these are being
raised to the fifth power.
But this is probably what
they want here.
We've simplified it and all of
the exponents are now positive
because we put the n
in the denominator.